[Music]
every look is an exotic food a paramour
less Portia young Camilla for you would
worm is Makiki California people's sir
those load non-forest trico the pesara
panel that we know acaba see Romeo
Ventura I'm at a carefully chosen you
belong since birth after you had a boy
for you support from stop this about how
I'm something you feel it before
the Moluccas monkey kita pilates our
salmon group so only here in the
barangay a famiiy luckily Pama patina
convoy para asistir a selasa
a un cambio a demon demon
mahira Honiton Kasimir a video Asif a
garbage cement Vedanta be locally Bob
Apodaca go bacana
prema k ki tamanna mensaje pootis pootis
Attica to mogul o un punto de un me
Caribbean mellimelon under PA you can
automatically young Camilla for mama
Tina Scylla for
[Music]
SATA me look for during serving a young
spirit Angela 10 for SEO Oh Luna oh
pardon young Gina Enya Pangani young ni
animating boughs elegant pune world
young silly hat feel Imahara beyond not
getting too big young saucer Emilio fuii
stop around
oyster support then parenting amis
human an example for you you can end up
winning would a young Amelia for is
actually but unknown in the whole world
paramananda she apparently kappa IM 10
below her up basura de basura
[Music]
this is the town of Banali it's in the
Philippines it's known for two things
gorgeous rice terraces and these amazing
wooden scooters
[Music]
so in here Robert do you gain where to
hit on viewpoint now if you go yeah and
Moon are being scooped up between wooden
is water Robert and the other men up in
now I used to carry rice and wood by
hand up and down the steep hills it took
forever so they came up with the idea of
using scooters wooden scooters going up
to speeds of 50 kilometers per hour
they're also revered as pieces of art
but he may Arco she wound up a hundred a
month daily and my nickel like 3:00
every April you'll find the people of
banal way gathered together for the
annual and bhayya festival and it's
famous scooter race
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
no big lure another day and discuss
always even when I wish my up accident
an omen with the new bethany mota Africa
orphan period is from Korea and if
another way I am ending school Perry
Athenian Mecosta their tea demon an
adventure
[Music]
Anika would in school area no my party :
after an exporter in an Athenian Empire
of no nepeta : or Torah mr. Putin kanawa
and mysterious port area hmm ah it then
portora en tae ha ha
Tijuana window tell you won't eat all
spent merry tune panel at Singapore town
and or Torah but now ah there's lots of
amazing food in the Philippines but
there's one amazing culinary tradition
that's big enough to feed an army
hi I'm Chuck and I own will fight Manila
butl Bootle what what Sabu to fight
[Applause]
I would Oh fight it's a feast set up on
banana leaves just a food pile in the
middle with everyone standing
shoulder-to-shoulder and the best part
is everyone eats with their bare hands
it originated with the Philippine
military soldiers took the practice home
and it went mainstream so mainstream
that chefs like Jeff now have full-time
jobs bringing boodle fights to the
masses the boodle fight is a
quintessential example of how Filipinos
value sharing especially when it comes
to food all this either verbally tried
to be enjoy the way it's meant to be
we love Balintawak market this is where
boodle fight comes together we'll be
needing the essentials for it chickens
seafood veggies dessert the sides and of
course the fruits and do not forget the
star of the show the banana leaves
choose time full already we start with a
messy part with a grilling first the
pork chicken a seafood and then you
slice the fruits steamed the veggies
together with the shrimp and the crab
and then slice all the sides and prepare
the table after setting up the banana
leaves it is important to look for the
center of the table and start from there
you can place the dessert and fruits
then on both sides start with the rice
pork chicken and seafood to make it
extra delicious at the sides literally
on the side of the table the Philippines
has a lot of choices when it comes to
food but none compared to the community
that develops when sharing a pile of
food barehanded with the people you love
[Music]
No Oh night Oh lalalalalala the Martin
Amana Joel Gargano sap2000 Teen Mom og
Lana 80,000 bases across the eating
macaroni Spanish okay before we go any
further
this is absolutely it's the small brown
and black bird whose nest are a highly
sought-after delicacy here in the
Philippines that people eat them in a
soup called
well bird's nest soup typically these
nests are found a high high up on cliffs
super hard to get you and we've been
taco my bottom 10,000 on [ __ ] that they
get think it out son so when these birds
lose then Eddie didn't kick them out
instead he gave them half his home down
similar chillin Tamara be so 1993 don't
see us a first floor behind sang
Priscilla
[Music]
seen Takeshi Onaga foxy a beer a bad
known and 10 minutes 20 minutes to be
laggy
parents ago so they boil it add some
veggies a bit of meat and voila bird's
nest soup little anchovy pneumococci and
a picked off by a shark in an epic tour
la la pasión go one more
[Music]
problema landeta Ximena million a pop
insane or Leila young I may know where
Polina referred ow mental or big snack
for my passive side of me behind a kayak
understandably so some people they just
can't appreciate the smell of 80,000
birds worth of droppings but Eddie and
swiftlets have an arrangement relation
and even a sub friend Ilana legacy and
eternal Shiva Nataraja bhai param
borders inaba eirin de la Frontera
militant
[Music]
getting your car washed is normally a
bit of a chore but here in Northridge
people are getting more car washes than
necessary and that's because of
something delicious lurking inside they
always say what we say the car wash how
come what happened how did you get here
it's really funny because nobody would
think that we are here I'm Lillian and
I'm the owner of millions bread and
sweets and we're located inside a car
wash
[Music]
Lillian opened her restaurant in the car
wash for one simple reason
she knew that being located in a car
wash would provide foot traffic and some
new clients when you walk into cruisers
you were confronted by the smells of
little tree air fresheners steering
wheel covers and other car cleaning
paraphernalia but you are also
confronted with the smell of home-cooked
Filipino food Filipino food is simple
but delicious with a lot of pork chicken
and beef and rice of course we cannot
eat our food without rice we are famous
for our hollow hollow our hollow hollow
they always say is the best in the west
it is to die for
as someone who ate three hollow hollows
in 24 hours I can attest it's really
great
Filipino food tends to be overlooked
internationally but it's gearing up to
be the next big thing in the culinary
world an average in a day we sell about
300 meals cooking is really a passion
for me yeah because if you are not
passionate with what you're doing then
you won't be able to succeed I'm really
so grateful and thankful that I have my
team because without them I am nothing I
think that's my secret so the next time
you treat yourself to a car wash
you can splurge and more than just a
pine-scented air freshener you can
splurge on that empanada scented plate
of Filipino food guaranteed to make your
car smell better than a little air
freshener ever could
[Music]